tell me iknow when did you that led your
heart side a whole new dish a whole new
dish of wet food and some kibbles and
some treats and then after party eat
okay hi everyone my name is Tamra
chambers and this is Tamra just saw and
last night I went and saw the
live-action remake of Aladdin a few
things before I jump in I won't be
spoiling it there won't be any specific
spoils what a weird phrasing I just used
also sorry if you hear construction my
next door is being demolished and
rebuilt and it's very inconvenient
street rats that I don't enjoy at all I
haven't so far enjoyed the live-action
remakes they just have such a bad
reputation now for just missing the mark
just being bland I think the whole point
is to reintroduce them to a younger
audience these classic tales but just
show the younger audience these Animated
Classics they're so good and if you're
gonna remake something and do it
live-action dude like the lesser-known
things we we have Beauty the Beast
already we don't need BV the beast cuz
we have it it's over here and it's
better I felt similarly with Dumbo and I
was going into this not expecting much I
love a laugh I grew up with it I love
the songs I love the characters I just
love that movie with all of my heart
it's very near and dear to my heart and
I think it's near and dear to a lot of
people's hearts and I also went in
having seen Prince Ali they have this
clip that they were showing yesterday on
YouTube they were showing on YouTube
have you heard of YouTube they posted on
YouTube I think yesterday a couple clips
from the film and Prince Ali was one of
them and it's the first thing and only
thing I saw before going in and it's
really lackluster it's low energy it's a
terrible representation of the film and
I went into this not expecting much
and then I feel like I'm gonna
disappoint a lot of people by saying
this I had the best time with this movie
you guys maybe it was I was going in
with such low expectations usually I
blame liking a movie on my energetic
audience but there was like three people
in the audience with my brother and I
and both of us were really not looking
forward to it and then the first opening
song came on and they started singing
and jumping around and dude like parkour
in between buildings and Taylor looked
over at me was like is this good I was
like yeah
and then I spent the whole movie like
that's just like
I said this on Twitter it's not a
perfect movie but what an annoying thing
to say good morning it's never gonna top
the original because the original is
incredible it brings some new things to
the table which I really enjoyed
there's a very epic song from our lead
Jasmine and it's kind of in the vein of
a like a let it go like a very like
strong song for for young women to
attach themselves to and I think it was
done well I was talking to a friend last
night who was like was it as obvious as
like the girls assembling at the end of
endgame it was like no it wasn't it
wasn't it was she builds up to it I
think going in everyone was just really
really worried about Jeannie because we
all know this Robin Williams portrayal
of the genie in the animated Aladdin is
incomparable and it's impossible to top
and it's just incredible and I think
instead of copying that Will Smith
decided to take a more chilled out Genie
approach and for me it worked
are there gonna be awkward moments yeah
he's like a 60 foot CGI blue Genie so
sure there's some there's some
awkwardness there he giving it his all
vote and that lackluster clip that a lot
of people were effort on Twitter last
night for why they weren't gonna see it
what a misstep for them to put that out
I think because that song was so
incredible and he was great and in the
energy was so so good the lackluster
earnest comes from his more chilled out
but when it comes to all together in the
full grand epic song and dance number it
doesn't feel lackluster it's just it was
a weird choice for them to to post that
but anyways he does have a more chilled
out cool vibe like a very Fresh Prince
vibe going on in his genie and I think
it works was the CGI bad I don't know I
don't really care about CG guys to me
did bother me at all I really don't
think it was that bad honestly it seems
like there was some jabs at other CGI
face I said this was detective Pikachu -
I think everything's now in my mind is
just a jab at Sonic every single movie
that comes out now is just gonna be a
jab at Sonic what do you got Godzilla
going in I wouldn't have imagined this
to be my problem with the movie but I
really didn't love Jafar and I don't
think that's at any faults to the actor
who played Jafar I think when you go in
as a very attractive young beautiful
evil man you're just not gonna you're
not gonna get the same effect as this
crazy over-the-top long chin
mother-fricker who is clearly evil and
older and creepy from the get-go
whereas like you're attractive and like
you just got it evil you know it's a
very different vibe that they cast than
what the cartoon looks like and that's
another thing with the genie - is like
these are all these are just animated
voices and then we're seeing these
cartoons and so it's never gonna match
up it's just a weird thing - you can't
compare it but there's no way for you
not to compare it so it's like it's just
a weird impossible ask and it's so odd
that they keep pushing for these live
actions Aladdin the actor who played
Aladdin was so freakin charming and had
such a good air about it like she just
was Aladdin I think jasmine was awesome
they really pushed for her to be even
more independent and strong but not
pandering lean pandering Lee so that's
not a word with the animals we've got
Iago Abu and Rajah and I really liked
them I didn't know how they were going
to attempt that I know
Iago talks a lot in the movie and in the
animated film and in this they have a
nice fun play with that with him being a
parents a bhoot was adorable I said ah a
lot of times and Raja was also just
really badass and cool and and yeah
there's CGI'd the whole time
but it didn't bother me again the CGI
really didn't bother me the song numbers
were fun I think comparatively if we're
just gonna compare it to Beauty and the
Beast which is I don't know I feel like
that's what people are doing these two
beloved like princess movies more so
than Cinderella
I think in my mind at least but beauty
in the Beast I was not impressed with
the vocals at all I was bummed about
them and they were great in this Jasmine
was slayed
she slayed it with the vocals Aladdin
did a lot of toxin but he acted his way
through it and he danced his way through
it and it still didn't bother me I was
into the song numbers a lot and I love
these songs so much this brought back
that nostalgic feels that I wanted these
to do when watching these live actions I
wanted to be brought back but just in a
more grand way and this did that it
brought me back it changed enough so I
didn't feel like Oh God
copy and paste and the lower-resolution
why doncha it also just elevated it it
was like that epic elevation of live
action one weird thing that I couldn't
get over especially in the first song
number first and second song numbers
there was just some weird camera work
there was like a weird effect put on it
I think they were trying to maybe
stylistically I don't know add style I
think maybe they were trying to take the
traditional dance that they were doing
and I had like a like a specific style
to it and it was kind of like sped up
and weirdly like jolty and places that
was super weird I don't really know what
that was but outside of that the dancing
was incredible and it was something that
I didn't realize that I had missed from
the first from the original the animated
film I didn't realize that I had missed
like the traditional dance and the
traditional costuming oh my god some of
those dresses the Jasmine wears or I
guess not dresses her a little like
floofy pants that are just iconic we
love I just I didn't realize every
single person in the movie is wearing
that like of course they are in the
animated - but it's so striking to see
it in person I feel like I'm really
apologizing a lot for liking this movie
at the end of the day I mean I totally
understand
he don't like the live actions because I
never have up until now and it's
difficult to give things a chance when
when they've disappointed you five times
I loved it though I really I want to go
see it again
which is crazy to me I would not watch
the live-action Beauty the Beast again
if you paid me maybe if you baby one
jump ahead of the breadline one swing
ahead of the sword I steal only what I
can't afford that is everything one jump
ahead of the lawmen that's all and
that's no joke
these guys don't appreciate that I'm
broke
that's a relatable that's relatable
[Music]
don't hold your breath
and I talk a lot about my cats leaving
space one swing ahead of the sword I
steal only what I can't afford
everything one jump
[Music]